[Music]
time now for our seen and unseen segment
where we expose what's really going on
behind the big cultural stories of the
day topics run the gamut today from the
media blackout on today's pro life walk
out and college campuses across the
nation and to the mayor of london
calling for get this nice control after
his city's murder rate is poised to pass
new york's for analysis we're joined by
New York Times bestselling author of the
will Wilder series Fox News contributor
Raymond Arroyo okay Raymond where we
starting to knife control got to start
with Sadiq Khan the Mayor of London's
knife control now this is the same man
just to remind everybody okay a few
years ago he rescinded the policy of
searching and stopping people who might
have knives might not dress because he
said it's racist and might be
Islamophobic wait did they only stop
Islamic well they did stop a lot of
Islamic folks because these are members
of gangs and that's it's mostly gang
activity on London that we're seeing
profiling five eight to fifteen knife
attacks a day in London what fifteen so
now he's passing these knife control
measures which means you cannot have
knives delivered to your home and you
can't order them online
what about wedding registries and steak
knives are great do without knives look
this is what he think in so knife set is
one of my favorite things you can get on
late-night TV borrowed from somebody
who's that's not all there are no new
ones this is what he tweeted this is
Sadiq Khan he said I'm joining the bore
oh sorry I'm reading no excuses there's
never a reason to carry a knife anyone
who does will be caught and they will
feel the full force of the law who's
never reason what's a knife now wait a
minute
if you're a baker you need a knife if
you're a butcher you need a knife if
you're a tech guy you know you work on
with it you need a knife oh my god we
use knives at my house - just cut stuff
for my favorite I found this
psychiatrist in London quoted in the
London Times why do we need these deadly
weapons at home we need curved
instruments so it's a country of butter
knives apparently now that's all you
need what does grab what is the West -
what's them gonna use at all
kill people with a butter knife I mean
what next axes a truck Sean Duffy was
just in here he's the big Columbo
Jackson was nothing nobody got a fish it
was a lumberjack remember the old days
alright so that's a this is a this is
what everybody used to joke about this
is hairspray
what's next hairspray that could be
deadly hairspray control I was thinking
piano wire we have to have a piano
control that's anything you can kill
with anything the corners of a desk you
know I don't know where this is uh
pro-life walkouts happen yeah hey I
didn't hear anything about them you had
this teacher on yesterday who was at
Rockland High School she raised a
question at the time of the gun walkouts
remember a month ago you had school
walkouts all over the country they were
covered with helicopters in line and leg
March in Washington but it wasn't only
that it was school walkouts yeah that
organized by the women's March okay well
now a student Brandon Gillespie at
Rockland high school he decided to stage
a pro-life walkout today 200 schools
participated school high schools 80
colleges no coverage at all no magazine
cover the kid couldn't score his brother
sockem
I don't know what it's he it was it's
ridiculous they're barely pictures of
this we'll put a few pictures up so you
can see but in very little video no
local or national coverage of this it's
an outrage and he did it
to prove the point and he proved it his
school district in Sacramento made
special provisions when the kids walked
out of school for gun control and they
were given use of school accessories
microphones and speakers they didn't
afford him those luxuries so now lawyers
are about to sue the school and they've
already threatened them saying this is
content discrimination tourists here we
are it's like we talked about last night
votes are terrible so now John Boehner
has been known to enjoy his cigs and
booze every now and then Merlot Merlot
oh please not just more low he's a
scotch drinker it's me perpetually tan
he's he's a great guy like
fëanor but now he's changed his thinking
don't you know on pot we all we call it
all cannabis that makes us feel better
to call it cannabis remember in in 2011
he said this he said I am unalterably
opposed to the legislation of marijuana
okay he was on the record
sweets out today he is now a member of
each joint acreage holdings touching
which is a cannabis distributor it
distributes to a little much money as he
make enough pot and wrecking the minds
of young thing I think that former
speakers finally seen green not only
marijuana but those Benjamins that are
coming through the door
this is realist oh no no we don't we
have enough problems in the country we
don't no more kids and they once adults
like oh it's fun and the kids are gonna
do it I mean I'm I'm adamantly I know
it's it's not the coolest thing to be
but I'm not I'm not wild about his
terrible effects and he claims it's
gonna help veterans since oh yeah they
always opioid addiction oh how do you
know it is addicting a lot person just
be honest
just be honest that if you want to make
a lot of money on pot just say you know
it's better than what going around the
country speaking and you know at ten
thousand bucks a pop they're gonna it's
gonna pay me a huge amount of money to
like sit on their board I mean whatever
it is just be honest you don't know
don't try to claim you're doing it for
the vets okay that is just that's that's
sad and then I have to share this video
I quickly President signed a piece of
legislation today to help outlaw online
human trafficking and prostitution there
was a survivor behind him and watch this
video can we show it do we have time I
am NOT a survivor I am MA
it's about being time
[Applause]
dancing during the signing she's doing a
joy it went on by the way we cut it off
unfortunately but it went on all right
well joy she was the first woman to sue
Backpage that's lost the feminist that
the feminists are all thrilled they love
back page apparently Raymond awesome
segment